[Music]
question there are nine movies behind me
could you tell me what they all have in
common and I'll give you a hint it's
something that makes all of these films
memorable and no it's not an actor a
theme or even the fact they've all
grossed an insane amount of money it's
something far more important we'll get
to that in a second
but first when I was 12 years old I
watched rocky for the first time and if
I'm gonna be brutally honest with you I
hated it
I had just watched this two-hour movie
only to find that spoiler alert he loses
in the end I felt betrayed cheated that
I was promised one movie but got another
what twelve-year-old me didn't
understand was that the movie wasn't
about whether he wins or loses it was
about something much greater it would
only be 15 years later that I realized
one of the fundamentals of great
storytelling buried within the core of
this film one that makes rocky a classic
and not to mention Best Picture winner
and the winner is rocky so in this
episode I want to examine the importance
of want versus need those movies I
mentioned at the top well they all
incorporated it's a device that allows
for a fast-moving plot while also
pushing a theme with emotional stakes so
let's take a look at some of these
differences and apply them using the
matrix Lord of the Rings and Toy Story
the first difference is that want is
external need is internal the external
want of a character is what drives the
plot forward
this is Frodo wanting to destroy the
ring
woody wanting to become Andy's favorite
toy again or neo wanting to save
humanity from the grips of our
mechanical overlords need on the other
hand is internal it is what our
characters need to learn about
themselves for them to grow and
ultimately fulfill their wand this is
Frodo realizing he needs Sam to complete
his journey
woody realizing the importance of
sharing and neo realizing that he must
believe in himself that he truly is the
one you'll notice I used the word
realizing here a lot and we'll come back
to that later the obstacles of wants and
eggs are also external and internal
wanting to destroy the ring huge army in
your way
wanting to be Andy's number one toy new
cooler toy in the way wanting to save
humanity from killer machines a bunch of
agents myths the obstacles for needs are
more internal they usually come from the
characters themselves holding them back
in some way from being their best self
which we'll talk about in our next
difference a want is known to your
character Frodo
neo and woody all know what they want
but the need is more complicated it
usually isn't known to them or if it is
that it's often rejected Frodo rejects
Sam leaving him to go on the journey
alone neo doesn't believe he's the one
Woody's quest to win back Andy only
results in him being ostracized by the
other toys and pushed further from his
goal he couldn't handle buzz cutting in
on your playtime good you woody didn't
want to face the fact that buzz just
might be Andy's new favorite toy woody
hasn't yet learned that he needs to
share if he's truly going to live a
fulfilling life he's in essence a
sheriff who doesn't share these are the
internal obstacles I refer to in my
first point third wants Drive plot needs
Drive theme going to Mordor traveling
into the matrix winning back Andy all
push the narrative plot of the film's
whereas need is the emotional drive it
is the theme what the film is trying to
say that ultimately gives us that
satisfying ending whether it be the
power of friendship believing in
yourself
[Music]
or the importance of sharing that isn't
to say a film can't have more than one
theme but I digress
forth wants are the fun needs are the
heart battles
explosions hijinks these are all the
results of the characters journeying
motivated by their external want needs
on the other hand are the emotional pull
those moments where characters and the
audience connect v watts are unique to
the character needs are universal let's
compare Lord of the Rings to Rocky
these two worlds couldn't be more
different from one another Rocky's want
revolves around a boxing match while
Frodo's is saving all of middle-earth
both of those are unique to their
character but their needs on the other
hand are similar they both need the love
support and friendship of someone else
if they are truly going to win the day
and there are countless other films
which share this theme it's this
Universal connection or these universal
themes that endear us to film now that
we've identified five basic differences
between want and need what happens when
a movie doesn't have one of them
Transformers including most of the films
in the franchise is an example of a film
with a strong clear want but no real
need how'd you know that
as far as transformers is concerned I'm
guessing you didn't come out of any of
those films emotionally move yeah no I'm
cool you know a female is working on my
engine that's because of the absence of
a strong need on the other hand you have
a film like Manchester by the sea it's
filled with emotional scenes a
dysfunctional character with a
tremendous need but the plot is lacking
a clear want we follow Casey Affleck's
character around for two hours and
nothing much happens his character is
reactive and not proactive in achieving
a goal which a want would have given him
and when a movie doesn't have either a
want or a need well you got Tammy partly
job so great films are able to marry
these two concepts into one creating
both an emotionally and captivating film
but let's dive a little deeper
specifically with the need a need is of
particular importance because it's
complex it's part of our psychology as
Jon Truby writes in the anatomy of story
the knee
is what the hero must fulfill within
himself in order to have a better life
it usually involves overcoming his
weakness and changing or growing in some
way in Tootsie Michael must overcome his
weakness of being an arrogant selfish
liar towards women in order to become a
better person and how does he do this
it's only by becoming a woman can he
realize the error of his ways and change
in Silence of the Lambs Clarice's
weakness is that she is inexperienced
suffering from haunting childhood
memories she's a woman in a man's world
her want is to stop Buffalo Bill but her
need is to overcome the ghosts of her
pasts and gain respect as a professional
in a man's world want and need even
though they have a lot of differences
shouldn't be distinct from one another
they are one interconnected web of
desires and conflict bouncing off one
another in the end coming together as a
unified whole creating a satisfying
story but the importance of want versus
need goes beyond film it says something
about ourselves about humanity it can
teach us about our own wants and desires
so back to rocky when I was a kid I
wanted nothing more than to see him win
but as I grew older I learned that's not
what I really needed stories are more
than the good guy winning all the time
they speak universal truths it's about
learning something greater than the
story itself that what we really need
might be in front of us but you just
haven't visualized
[Music]
hey if you liked what you saw make sure
to LIKE subscribe and check out the
other videos below
[Music]